in a prison in Seattle the color pink
was used as mind control how does this
make you feel does it make you feel
passive make a fist does it feel weak
drunk tank pink passive pink cooled down
pink Baker Miller pink P six one eight
whatever you call it the idea that pink
might make you weak is actually science
kinda it's in the 1960s the scientist
Alexander shouts wanted to find out if
colors could affect the way you felt he
was a believer in this German theory
that you could use the colors people
chose as a way to understand their inner
mental state and he wanted to see if he
could reverse it if he could basically
make you feel things by showing you
certain colors he came across one shade
that was special so he got a hundred and
fifty three volunteers and he had them
hold out their arms in front of them and
he showed them either a blue piece of
cardboard or a pink piece of cardboard
and he had a volunteer pushing their
hands down as hard as he could a hundred
and fifty one of a hundred and fifty
three people were weaker when they were
looking at the pink he also tested this
was slightly more scientific methods of
having people use a hand grippy thing
that tested how hard they gripped he
found a loss of strength between six and
23% it had effects on people's
cardiovascular system they calmed down
so he started talking about this at one
of his talks two guys Baker and Miller
saw his presentation they happened to
run a prison this is actually a naval
prison and then they said hey what if we
paint the drunk tank pink that's what
they did so the Navy's report was that
since undertaking this experiment on
March 1st 1979
there have been no incidents of erratic
or violent behavior during the
confinement have you ever wondered what
to do with a drunken sailor or what to
do with a drunken sailor what to do with
a drunken sailor put him in a pink room
as far as they were concerned it was a
huge success and this caught on penal
systems around the country began
painting their rooms pink San Bernardino
in California and painted their Juvenile
Detention Center pink and said they
actually couldn't leave the the
delinquents in there for too long or
they'd become too weak when the power of
pink became one of these well-known
truths about ten years later in 1988
some scientists tried to replicate the
results and they couldn't do it they
could not show any measurable
differences in grip strength in heart
rate it was a wash but the cat was out
of the bag
to this day prison systems are still
experimenting with Baker Miller pink
Switzerland just painted parts of eight
different prisons this shade of pink
well the science on this remains pretty
sketchy uses for Baker Miller pink have
been proposed from corporate break rooms
to the inside of ambulances panic rooms
airport security or mental facilities
for catastrophe areas like natural
disaster relief areas regardless of the
science behind it for modern-day prisons
the color of control is Bink bright
bubblegum pink the pinkest pink you can
pink I mean there's an irony in this too
which is that our cultural associations
of pink are new in the turn of the
century pink was the traditional boys
color like what if it's true
and pink actually creates passivity and
it has been thrust upon the women of the
world as a way to make them docile
consumers of home goods and Dolls our
daughters are being brainwashed by pink